internet culture is a absolute threat to
existing power structures it is going to
be one of the most disruptive things
that we we see coming forth in terms of
expression because people are finally
realizing that they have power in their
voice my name is ben handi founder and
CEO of cheeseburger cheeseburger is one
of the world's largest destinations for
humor my belief is that internet culture
will at some point be indistinguishable
from popular culture we're already
seeing the mainstreaming of internet
culture you're already seeing people who
normally wouldn't be considered a geek
or Internet nerd participating in the
remake singing creative content and then
they know what a meme is and that's
gonna continue to grow and once internet
culture becomes dominant it will be
popular culture just as the underground
music movement of rock and roll became
popular culture the remix thing and the
do-it-yourself culture is fundamentally
changing our perception of our ability
to influence others we've been living in
a world where things have been told to
us there were people who created content
and there were people who created who
consumed content and there was a big
line in the middle and you had to be
ordained by a publisher or TV network or
a movie studio to create content and
that's no longer true everybody now is a
publisher you can take your phone and
take an HD video you can take your phone
and send photos to the internet you can
write emails that are funny you can
write tweets that may be passed on to
millions of people the world has
fundamentally changed in the way we
perceive our ability to influence and
that's why you see a lot of people get
really scared when there's you know
customer revolts on Twitter and when
people are upset and you see the
anti-sopa movement when I came out and
said we're gonna move all of our domains
off of GoDaddy and go somewhere else we
only had about a little less than a
thousand domains on GoDaddy but they
responded it was one guy but I could
reach a lot of people when you let
people do what they want to do they will
do what they want to do and it turns out
that for the last 50 years we've been
delivering things media in a certain way
that was imperfect and we thought that
that was perfection we thought that was
the pinnacle television in the 1950s and
60s when it was just coming into life
you saw the formation of soap operas and
sitcoms
newscaster and those are formats that
were native to television and what
you're seeing now is the internet it's
finding its native format and it tends
to be the remix thing of images or
blogging or what have you so that's what
we're finding today is that we're
finding ways that this medium is
particularly good at and as we transfer
more of our attention to mobile or to
applications you're going to see
different types of formats come to life
I see the internet self-identifying with
a handful of set of core beliefs one is
that information must be free and it
must flow everywhere that the internet
must be neutral it may not favor one
government or one country or one set of
religious groups and three that you are
free to take the media that you find and
you are free to make it your own
that you can use that media you can use
that quote we can use that clip to
express your idea and spread it on
internet culture is disruptive and the
reason it's good is that it gives people
power for the first time to be socially
disobedient in other words take the
social capital that they've earned and
use it and towards a cause that they
really believe in and that's a type of
activism that is very much more lower
level low heat but it is going to be
very influential because a lot of people
do it and you actually saw this with
Kony 2012 which was a fascinating
example of this where one man created a
viral video and lots of people who were
you know armchair activists started
doing things for this cause and then
there was actually a backlash of people
saying you know maybe you shouldn't
believe everything you read on the
Internet and both types of activism had
the same core of I can do this from my
chair right none of it was people in the
streets none of it was violent none of
it was you know I'm gonna go on TV and
say these things and try to influence
the public it was very much people
talking to one another
and people who self-identified making a
decision for themselves as to which camp
they wanted to be in we tend to take
shortcuts in how he described the
Internet community human beings aren't
just one sided
we're very multifaceted you can be a
troll one day and be really nice to
another is there a nihilistic element to
it absolutely is their self destructive
on to the United absolutely but the same
self-destructive people will also do
amazingly creative things and you cannot
throw out one side and and and expect
the other side to survive they're the
same people
[Music]